uh demons uh Dark Souls I I wouldn't I
didn't hide behind a shield I just
rolled out of the way oh you know that
that's generally where I stick to but
you know I'm looking at this game and uh
the boss thematics is pretty good I will
say this is an easier game than most
from software games I don't think it's
uh excessively hard besides
lubu's a pain
there there's a couple people that
definitely you don't want to mess with
uh they're a lot of the people that fly
uh when they're flying they're very hard
to hit they're very hard to you know
predict they're extremely unpredictable
you got some teleporting uh bosses in
this game I will say that the co-op in
this game is all God awful
I don't expect it to the way it is it
doesn't really you know how like well
first off you know uh you know how
in redfall let's say I jump in your game
called